the g20 summit of the 20 wealthiest
nations and
emerging powers is hosted by saudi
arabia this year
but the country has repeatedly faced
international criticism
over human rights concerns well ahead of
the primarily
online forum members of the european
parliament urged
commission president ursula fonder lion
and the president of the european
council charles michelle
to boycott the event
jamal khashoggi an outspoken critic of
saudi arabia's government
murdered in a saudi consulate blog
arrived badawi publicly flocked and
sentenced to 10 years in prison for
allegedly insulting islam
activist lujina lahatrol detained for
seeking the right to
drive those are just three examples of
human rights violations in saudi arabia
the country hosting this year's g20
summit
since assuming the g20 presidency the
government of saudi arabia has been hard
at work
trying to rebrand its image so there's a
large global
public relations campaign underway in
order to encourage investment
in the country and yet behind these
initiatives and reform the reality on
the ground is that there is a brutal
crackdown
being led by the saudi authorities
against its own nationals
that's the reason why european lawmakers
are taking a stand
the eu cannot remain silent last month
they passed a resolution calling on eu
officials to downgrade their
participation in the summit even though
it's only a virtual event
mark tarabella is spearheading the
campaign we ask for the downgrading why
because an empty seat is not a good
policy
it would be better to send not a high
delegation
level but a delegation who
is able to deliver a message a strong
message toward the saudi authorities
the lawmakers also sent a personal
letter to european commission president
ozola fonder lion and european council
president
xil michelle we asked the commission for
their response and were told the summit
was too important
not to attend we've been raising our
concerns and we discussed further
how to improve the human rights
situation the protection of human rights
in the kingdom
and we will continue to pay utmost
attention to this question
eu officials say it's important to
maintain dialogue
and keep communication channels open but
human rights groups argue
leaders must use this summit as an
opportunity to ramp up the pressure on
riyadh
and hold the country to account for
human rights abuses
they demand that at least all the
women's rights activists currently in
jail should be released as soon as
possible
after all one of the themes of the g20
is women's empowerment
for more let's ask christian bloot who
specialises in international trade with
the bertelsmann institute
here in germany christian welcome saudi
arabia is hosting this weekend's g20
summit
the oil wealthy kingdom though was
recently and repeatedly
accused of major human rights violations
are they the right host
well whether or not they are the right
host um
they are probably not but what's
actually important is that the
international policy response to covet
has been lagging
behind the challenge for quite some time
now and it's really important that the
international community gets its act
together
and steps up the measures that are taken
against the pandemic and its economic
fallout
so i'd say it's very important to talk
even if this meeting is hosted by a
somewhat unsavory host
christian the summit starts as you
mentioned as we hit a critical phase
of the kovit 19 pandemic all of these
economies represented
need the vaccine to bounce back how much
will competition
for access to the vaccine be part of
these discussions
what's really important is that we find
a strategy to distribute
the vaccine worldwide if we don't manage
to do this
the covet virus can come back from a
remote corner of the world and will
haunt us again
so it's really important that we find a
way to coordinate
the distribution of vaccines that we do
so effectively
and that the financing gap which
currently still persists
is closed um i guess there will probably
an element of competition who gets it
first
which will be unavoidable but what's
really important is that eventually
everyone gets it christian from
kovid to the great unknown of this forum
this time around
this is likely donald trump's last
appearance on the world
stage as u.s president what are the
other nations expecting
from the outgoing president
well although this is a really important
meeting i think
expectations are very low and that has
to do with donald trump
his america first approach has turned
out to be extremely short-sighted
it hasn't served america well and it
hasn't served the international
community well
when i said that the international
policy response has really been lagging
behind the challenge what i meant is
we should have acted much earlier than
we have and offered that relief to poor
countries
rich countries have thrown an enormous
amount of money
at combatting covict and poor countries
haven't been able to do that in the same
degree
so donald trump will probably go down as
a president that has
hampered an effective response to this
massive crisis and everyone i think is
waiting for joe biden
to assume the presidency and to see more
leadership
from the united states in combating this
crisis
and others christian blood project
manager for the
bertelsmann foundation thank you so much
thank you
you